[Musik]
mit jedem tag mit dem die ukraine ihre
hauptstadt kiew halten da gewinnen sie
diesen krieg und mit jedem tag mit dem
die russen kiew eben nicht erobern da
verlieren sie diesen krieg es ist
eigentlich so einfach denn alles in
diesem krieg das dreht sich um die stadt
kiew die ganze welt schaut auf diese
ukrainische hauptstadt im norden des
landes denn die russen die wollen hier
fördern um den präsidenten dort zu
stürzen zu verhaften vielleicht sogar zu
ermorden um einen präsidenten zu
installieren der in ihrem interesse
handelt ein marionetten präsident und
die ukraine die wollen natürlich ihre
heimat in ihrer hauptstadt verteidigen
und zwar mit solchen verteidigungs
ringen die gebaut wurden die angelegt
wurden und die wir ihnen heute hier mit
unserem virtuellen z genau erklären
wollen der sinn dieser
verteidigungslinien der ist es die
russischen soldaten den russischen
vormarsch abzubremsen den gesamten kampf
dorthin zu lenken wo es die ukraine
wollen das gefecht dann und dort zu
führen wo sie es wollen und am ende die
russen zu stoppen und zu zermürben was
wir ganz am anfang dieses krieges schon
gesehen haben das ist das springen von
brücken denn kiew liegt an einem
riesigen fluss und über diesen fluss da
komme ich eben nur über indem ich
brücken verwendet das gilt für das
russische militär genauso wie für
zivilisten und die ukraine die haben
eben genau diese brücken nach kiew
gesprengt um die russischen panzer zu
stoppen wir haben unglaubliche
heldengeschichten gehört von einzelnen
ukrainischen soldaten die
zurückgeblieben sind die manuell diese
sprengladungen gezündet haben und dabei
und damit ihr eigenes leben gegeben
haben aber irgendwann da kommt dann der
kampf eben nach hier rein in die vororte
in die außenbezirke und ins stadtzentrum
und wir haben ihn hier aufbereitet und
vorbereitet womit genau sich die
menschen in kiew verteidigen was ihr
waffenarsenal ihre ausrüstung ist
ganz banal wenn man belagert wird wenn
man umstellt ist dann braucht man
natürlich wasser und fertignahrung denn
wer drei tage lang nichts gegessen
nichts getrunken hat der kann natürlich
auch nicht kämpfen kein gefecht führen
wir sehen hier vorne granaten die für
den häuserkampf ganz entscheidend und
ganz wichtig sind wir sehen drohnen und
zwar in sie genau hinschauen das sind
zivile drohen drohnen die man im
geschäft kaufen kann die die ukraine
einsetzen und zuschauen sind zwei drei
vier blöcke weiter vielleicht schon
russische panzer wir sehen
scharfschützengewehre hier wie hier das
legendäre 300
scharfschützengewehren womit man zb im
hinterhalt effektiv russische truppen
bekämpfen kann ak 47 sturmgewehre die in
den letzten tagen und wochen massenhaft
ausgegeben wurden die standardwaffe in
diesen tagen für die ukraine wir sehen
hier vorne mehrere unterschiedliche
typen von panzerabwehrraketen
ganz entscheidende waffen mit denen sich
die ukraine so erfolgreich und man muss
das so sagen heldenhaft gegen diese
russischen stahl ungetüm die sich
dadurch ihre städte bewegen während
ihnen die ganz entscheidend sind wenn
man den vorstoß stoppen will und so was
auch banales wie eben benzin denn wenn
ich selbst kein benzin mehr habe weil
ich um steht bin weil ich um lage bin
dann kann ich natürlich auch selbst
nicht mehr heizen keine fahrzeuge mehr
betreiben alles solche dinge wir wollen
jetzt wenn wir das arsenale vor uns
sehen einen echten experten dazu holen
oliver schneider ehemaliger hauptmann
des legendären ksk und da eben
ausgebildet für den häuserkampf für den
hinterhalt herr schneider wenn sie jetzt
dieses ganze waffenarsenal vor sich
sehen was würden sie nehmen um kiew zu
verteidigen
als gelernter infanterist würde ich mir
zuallererst gedanken bezüglich meiner
eigenen stellung machen wie kann ich auf
den fein am besten wirken und mein
risiko des beschusses
minimieren es gilt der grundsatz wirkung
vor deckung wenn ich diese entscheidung
getroffen habe mache mir gedanken über
waffen kampfmittel stellungs bau und
logistik ein waffen mix aller in
phantastischer waffen ist wichtig
sturmgewehre maschinengewehre aber vor
allem panzerfäusten handgranaten minen
schützen ab wenn ihnen sogenannte claims
aus amerikanischer produktion hand flamm
patronen und so weiter ergeben einen
tödlichen mix für den feind ich muss mir
gedanken machen wo ich das
maschinengewehr einsätze wo der
scharfschütze am besten wirken kann wo
die panzerfaust die höchste trefferquote
erzählen kann und wie ich mich im
gebäude oder in den gebäuden die mir
zugeordnet wurden bewegen kann zudem
muss ich mir gedanken zur deckung machen
ich muss eventuell wände und decken
abstützen löcher ins gebäude springen so
dass ich mich bewegen kann und vieles
mehr zu ihrer frage ganz konkret was
wäre mir am wichtigsten
maschinen mehr kampfmittel panzerfaust
und die möglichkeit sich direkt
verschieben zu können schneider wir
kommen gleich noch mal zurück zu ihnen
ja wir haben es gerade von hauptband
schneider gehört es kommt eben nicht nur
auf die waffen an es kommt natürlich
auch auf den ort an und wie ich diesen
ort vorbereite also die stadt die vor
mir liegt hinter mir liegt diese stadt
verteidige und wie ich das genau
vorbereitet wie man das am besten macht
die stadt vorbereiten das zeigen wir
ihnen jetzt denn das a und o dafür dass
ist das blockieren von straßen zum
beispiel indem ich alte lkws müllautos
busse voll mit schrott und schublade und
so strasen versperre da kommt dann eben
kein panzer mehr durch oder auch ganz
klassisch panzersperren wie wir sie seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg kennen und die
eben den weg versperren warum macht man
das einmal den angriff abbremsen führt
dazu dass ganze konvois und colón in den
stau kommen abbremsen der motor läuft
aber weiter sie verbrauchen weiter
benzin und wir wissen die russen sie
haben in diesem krieg große
nachschubprobleme hier wird dann aber
weiter benzin verbrannt benzin
der dann später vielleicht gar nicht
mehr zu diesen fahrzeugen gebrannt
werden kann das will ich als verteidiger
und das andere ist natürlich abbremsen
und den verkehr den panzer dahin lenken
wo ich ihn treffen kann das wollen wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen denn hier haben wir
eine straße vorbereitet und in diese
straße da wird gleich ein panzer rollen
und dann werden sie genau sehen was
passiert wenn dieser panzer am ende in
so eine s kurve kommt denn hier haben
die verteidiger einen checkpoint
angelegt und das zwingt den panzer dazu
langsam zu fahren und sehen das seitlich
zu fahren seitlich ist für die
verteidiger ganz wichtig denn der panzer
der ist an der seite besonders
verwundbar wenn ich hier und sie sehen
dass links der mann der hat bereits eine
panzerabwehrrakete wenn der den panzer
jetzt angriff von der seite dann ist der
panzer da eben besonders verwundbar und
auch das eine szene die wir in der
ukraine immer wieder erleben von dächern
aus von hochpunkten aus werden gegner
eben bekämpft werden die russischen
angreifer bekämpft denn natürlich höher
ist immer ein vorteil in diesem krieg
ist immer strategisch etwas das mir
vorteil bietet wenn wir jetzt all diese
situation sehen und sehen was ich machen
kann als verteidiger dann wollen wir
genau darüber nochmal mit unserem
experten sprechen und ihn fragen was er
tun würde in so einer situation
hauptband schneider wie würden sie die
stadt vorbereiten für so eine schlacht
gegen die russen
sparen hindernisse und hemmnisse sind im
orts- und häuserkampf essentiell das
lernt man nach und kommen auch an der
infanterieschule bundeswehr in
hammelburg und die dortige horz kampf
anlage kenne ich aus meiner aktiven zeit
noch zu genüge man lernt dort wie
komplex angriff und verteidigung von
ortschaften sind mit sperren gleich den
feind nicht nur aufhalten ich kann ihnen
auch steuern wenn er an einer sperre zum
stehen kommt dann nimmt er eventuell
eine andere route und das wählen diese
ausweichroute habe ich natürlich genau
so gewollt diese bescheide ich dann
entsprechend mit mit feuer oder ich
verzichte er ganz bewusst auf sparen
weil ich den feind in einen hinterhalt
locken ich habe viele möglichkeiten mich
als verteidiger einzurücken ich kenne
die stadt ich kenne in die kanalisation
ich habe hinterhalte vorbereitet und
häuser zur verteidigung eingerichtet
sparen kann ich aus unterschiedlichsten
materialien richten quer stehende
traktoren lkw busse etc es muss aber
immer der grundsatz lauten dass eine
sperre überwacht werden muss so dass der
feind diese nicht einfach aus dem weg
räumt ich kann und muss sparen
zusätzlich mit ihnen und versteckten
ladungen sichern umso einräumen zu
erschweren hauptmann schneider
ehemaliger hauptmann beim ksk vielen
dank in diesen russischen angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine hat da haben wir
vieles gesehen natürlich vor allem
großes menschliches leid auf der einen
seite und dann diese unglaubliche
aggressivität der russen auf der anderen
und dann ist da aber auch verzweiflung
wie zum beispiel bei anleitungen der
ukraine die sie an ihre eigenen leute
herausgegeben haben wie man am besten
molotow-cocktails herstellt wie hier vor
mir im bild molotow-cocktails das ist
eigentlich mit die primitivste art der
verteidigung man schüttet benzin in
einer flasche stopft ein lappen rein
zündet den an und wirft ihnen dann am
ende in seiner verzweiflung auf
russische militärfahrzeuge ukraine die
anleitung herausgegeben um zu erklären
wo man diese russischen militärfahrzeuge
am besten treffen soll zum beispiel am
tank des fahrzeugs dann klar wenn ich da
das auto treffe dann habe ich vielleicht
die chance dass der tank in flammen geht
explodiert das auto ausgeschaltet wird
genauso der motorblock auch etwas was
bei fahrzeugen vielleicht besonders
sensibel ist wenn ich da schaden schaffe
zuzufügen dann fällt das auto vielleicht
aus genau so geht das für die reifen
auch die reifen werden in diesen
anleitungen genannt und im optimalfall
da gelingt es mir dann das auto eben zum
liegen zu bringen vielleicht braucht
auch schon der rauch aus dass der fahrer
nicht mehr weiterfahren kann oder es ist
sogar so dass die fahrerkabine in brand
gerät was am ende natürlich oder sehr
wahrscheinlich tödliche folgen für die
besatzung dieser fahrzeuge hat die
ukraine die müssen aber natürlich
trotzdem ständig und dauern darauf
vorbereitet seien gefasst sein dass sie
von den russen bombardiert werden dass
sie mit artilleriegeschossen geschossen
werden dass aus der luft raketen kommen
dass flugzeuge oder hubschrauber kommen
die sie mit raketen beschießen denn das
ist nun mal der krieg der russen so
führen sie den krieg gegen zivil gebäude
gegen armee gegen alles was sich ihnen
in den weg stellt wir wollen ihnen
zeigen was die ukraine dagegen machen
können sich zum beispiel verstecken es
klingt so unglaublich banal aber
einfache netze gespannte lagen die
können schon ganz viel auslösen jon
spencer ein us major der hat erzählt
dass im irak und in syrien dieses genau
das getan hat um sich vor den modernsten
amerikanischen satelliten die hunderte
millionen dollar gekostet haben zu
verstecken und am ende die terroristen
sich so unbekannt in der stadt bewegt
haben genau das müssen die ukraine jetzt
auch machen daneben müssen sie natürlich
wenn diese geschosse kommen diese
todbringenden ladungen der russen in
keller gehen im bunker gehen und sich
dort schutz suchen will kann das von
anfang an gesehen in diesem krieg das zb
u-bahn-schächte genutzt werden dass man
hier in deckung geht weil dort die wände
besonders dick sind das müssen die
ukraine aber auch ausnutzen und zb
tunnel graben denn die einzelnen
verstecke diese bunker im optimalfall
sind die miteinander verbunden damit ich
eben meine truppen bewegen kann
unterirdisch an einem stelle
verschwinden kann und an einer anderen
stelle wieder rauskommen kann so auch
nachschub organisieren kann
munitionslager organisieren kann und so
eben am besten meine truppen in der
stadt verteilen wir haben also gehört es
braucht den richtigen waffenmissbrauch
die richtige planung für den ort des
gefechts und es braucht am ende eine
starke verteidigung rückzugsorte an die
ich mich sicher zurückziehen kann und
wenn die ukraine all das tun dann können
sie am ende den krieg die schlacht um
ihre hauptstadt kiew gewinnen und damit
womöglich auch den krieg gegen die
russen überhaupt gewinnen und damit
zurück zu bild live
[Musik]